from timcast.com
Alex Jones says deep state will try to
assassinate former president Donald
Trump radio show host says that corrupt
government actors will never allow Trump
to make good on a promise to prosecute
them for their criminal activity you
want to know I found this so interesting
is that RFK Jr said something similar
recently he said that he has to be aware
of what they did to his uncle and and
his dad right yeah and so he's like it's
a very real possibility
if we've got we've come to a point
call it whatever you want believe
whatever you want to believe the left
can say far right conspiracy theory
whatever it's come to the point where
high profile Personalities in this
country including one presidential
Contender himself RFK are are afraid
that there is a potential assassination
looming for two different prominent high
profile contenders and dare I say Front
Runners when we're talking about like
let's let's say the top five candidates
who could win RFK Jr they may call him
Fringe they may say it's never gonna
happen but he's polling really well and
so he's certainly pulling better than
any other Republican outside of trump
and DeSantis and I think he's got more
favorability than all other candidates
now you got Alex Jones saying this a lot
of people will say oh but Alex Jones is
crazy and I'm like listen
we know that they're going to try to Pro
I'm sorry try to they're literally
Prosecuting Trump I don't know about
going this far but it's been said by
other people and it's been said before
and if RFK is saying something similar
to himself it just I don't know it speak
to the times does it speak to the times
that we're in that we're at this point I
was just talking about how the
institution of this country is Swiss
cheese like the fabric of this nation is
being burned out from the inside and
it's and it's fumbling and breaking
apart did you could you have ever
believed
10 years ago that we'd get to a point
where a contender for the presidency
would say he fears assassination and
when there's actual talk in the
political space among high-profile shows
of a of the former president who was
running potentially being assassinated
like people wouldn't believe you if you
said that's where we'd be
you mentioned or maybe you would I don't
know you mentioned uh earlier the left
talk having a problem with this the left
should not be or is in no position to
make comments about whether or not the
CIA will or will not do something
because the CIA has been the boogeyman
of the left for literally ever if you
ask anyone that's an actual leftist why
socialism has not taken hold globally it
is going to be the CIA that's what
they're gonna say they're gonna blame
CIA they do it all the time so
the idea that that the left would reject
a conspiracy theory about the CIA
killing a president or possibility no no
they they love the CAA now they love the
FBI now like because they control it but
but took it over that the the general
umbrella left not leftists like Fringe
leftists still don't like them they hate
the United States institutions yeah I
get that but like
the liberals who used to pretend to
align with the left now absolutely but
um I wonder
is is this our last presidential
election
and I mean that in a hyperbolic sense
like is this is this going to be a
tumultuous and strange election that
breaks the the routine we've expected of
every four years in that it's not going
to be Joe Biden
the way the reporters are coming after
him the way the hunter Biden scandal is
going I'm hearing that that Biden's the
Joe's lawyered up already yeah maybe
Michelle Obama and David Newsome yeah
maybe Michelle's going to win let me
Michelle she's going to dominate I don't
know I don't know that's what Alex was
saying he thinks he's gonna be Michelle
he was like it's gonna be Gavin Michelle
or Michelle Gavin and I I've been saying
something similar too like if Michelle
Obama ran I said this and then Obama
will run the run the office from his
basement in his sweats just like he
joked about wanting to do but but the
question is do they have the wherewithal
to maintain the machine that they failed
to maintain for the past eight years I
think so I think Michelle's the kind of
person that can be shocked out of it
like her and Barack are like asleep in
the machine but I I sense they're a
single person
we're talking about look Donald Trump
should not have got elected it was
supposed to be Hillary Clinton and Trump
won because they screwed up bad
2020 comes around and they went insane
in their panic and Desperation to the
point where Boston Globe reported they
entertain the possibility of the West
Coast seceding from the union of trump
won again
now 2024 is coming around and Trump's in
the polls doing really well and they
know Biden ain't got it so what do they
have you're right last ditch at last
effort Michelle Obama but can even with
Michelle Obama
can they muster up the machine they need
to defeat Donald Trump if they can do it
Biden they can do it with Michelle that
was during coven
yeah but I like Michelle Mann and I'm
not even like a I'm not registered
Democrat or any of that but I I really
like that girl I think she is really
smart she's the reason Barack ever had
the confidence to become president she
has two great kids as far as I can tell
what does that have to do that I think
she'd be a good leader I mean I I I
think she's stable I think she's willing
to to say no to the crap the bad stuff
and and overturn the what's gone too far
Barack Obama
killed a 16 year old American kid I know
that's that's political command but I
don't like it see I I think Michelle
Obama will be a despotic tyrant with a
smile on her face just like they all are
they all depends
I'm not gonna get behind him the and
this is the funny thing because I got
the DeSantis people who are all mad at
me and they lie so much holy crap
they're like Tim's they're tweeting
about claiming that I said Trump will
magically change his behavior and become
the best president I'm like when did I I
said he has a slightly higher chance of
firing people that's it I want to see
the corruption dismantled and is Trump
going to be the greatest president of
all time no on foreign policy maybe but
that's just one specific area there's a
lot of bad things he did in foreign
policy as well but in terms of firing
corruption ripping it from the system
Trump Wants Revenge I'll take what I can
get does it mean he's gonna be good no
the problem with that is that he
announced it that he announced he was
gonna go in and arrest all these people
like
but you don't but that's why they won't
let them win because you can't show your
hand beforehand and be like these are my
secret plans once I get in I'm gonna end
your career you're like no they're not
going to let you get in dude he he did
play ball the first time around he tried
yeah he tried playing ball I thought it
was gonna be a traditional American
presidency that was his big
miscalculation yep and he he brought in
people we didn't like and we criticized
him for it and he kept people on that he
should have fired and we criticized him
for it because he thought I'm gonna work
with him to mess my abilities I'm gonna
do my agenda and they were not having it
now he's like I realize the truth they
must be dismantled yeah but I and I'm
not saying he's wrong or right I'm not
saying he's wrong but he should not in
my opinion he should not have said that
out loud he should have went in there
won the job and then did it without
telling anyone he was coming because if
they know you're coming they're they're
going to fortify but they did they
accused him of being a traitor working
for the Soviet Union not even Russia the
Soviet Union Jonathan Shake goes on
MSNBC and he's like Trump might be a
Soviet it's like he doesn't exist he
didn't say that explicitly he said Trump
may have been a Russian asset going back
to the 80s okay that would mean he was a
Soviet asset you know but meanwhile the
Dems in this kind of I mean there was a
letter from Ted Kennedy to uh the
Soviets asking him to help uh fight
against Reagan in in the early 80s like
it was always the Dems that it aligned
with uh with the Soviets and they were
always Partners didn't Bernie Sanders go
yeah in the Soviet Union so it was great
yeah that's crazy like people are
disappearing dying being beaten
there were there were there were plenty
of people in the west that were very
prepared to write apology uh pieces for
the Soviet Union there were people and
the at the New York Times I forget the
guy's name he was writing during the the
holiday more not yet well the Holland no
more yes but there I'm thinking about uh
I was thinking about something that
someone was writing just writing glowing
pieces about Stalin and he was at the
New York Times like writing great pieces
about Stalin while Stalin was you know
killing millions of people and throwing
people in in the gulags and while the
gulag system was at its at its peak
there were people in the west writing
glowing pieces about Stalin because they
believe in the ideology and they
believed whatever you need to do to get
to the Communist Utopia to remake man as
a socialist was fine that's the the
reason why
why the the left always makes excuses
for the horrors and atrocities that the
left does is because if we just get past
this hard part if we just get past the
part where a bunch of people die then
we'll have remade Society into a
socialist Utopia and then we'll have the
perfect society that we all where
everyone has what they need and Etc so
it'll be worth killing off this many
people or whatever because once we get
through it once you get through this bad
part then the Utopia is on the other
side it's just that you never get
through it the bodies just pile up and
pile up and that's why you end up with
dozens of millions dead look they want
to eliminate free radicals to create
what I would describe as a organism
system they want the people who are like
I would like to be an accountant and
nothing more and then they want that
person to stay in their box and do what
they're told we're free radicals we're
bouncing around doing all this crazy
individualism stuff that's bad for the
expansion of the machine into a higher
state but it is good for America
it's good for it's good for Humanity the
world for human progress a decentralized
system is better than a centralized one
yeah because then it's no Elon Musk said
this right because then it's better it's
not decentralized because then uh if it
not everything goes to hell right not
everything fails at the same time you
want diversity when it comes to Nations
you don't want one world government
let's think about this way
little single-celled organism runs
around lives it's life it's fine it eats
it lives it dies it happens if the cell
next to it dies it's fine ah but in a
human if a clump of cells in one part of
the body fails every other cell dies off
that's the risk of a centralized system
if a human dies it causes damage to the
greater system let's say the human's a
farmer Farmer dies okay well someone's
got to pick up the slack and replace
that that person that happens in a body
like normal a cell can die off and then
gets replaced by another one however if
we centralize everything then the risk
of catastrophic Cascade failure
exponentially increases because you
cannot replace an accountant with a
plumber
within a decentralized system it's much
more it's much easier to fill gaps more
fluid like water and less rigid yeah I
guess you have an amalgam of a
centralized decentralized system so just
like a human body you have a brain which
is kind of a pseudocentralized or area
of the system you have a heart you have
a stomach all these like minor
centralization so like in any truly
decentralized system you have larger
nodes which tend to be seemingly a
little more of a central area where more
people are are coagulating but if one
node fails it can be replicated replaced
or the machine won't the whole system
doesn't collapse yeah you don't want to
rely on any one area of the system ever
if you have to rely on one area for the
system to function that's a big
vulnerability it's like we have two
kidneys if one fails then we might
survive you know we probably will with
one you know
think about that in terms of if I want
to centralize humanity into one big
machine one big system
you get one one centralized node failing
that can't be replicated and the Machine
will collapse Humanity collapses and
that has to build itself Back Up From
the Ashes I think decentralization works
way better in terms of everything the
speed of progress especially the
happiness of people in general the
Soviet Union didn't work people were
miserable they were starving they were
miserable and the greatest Point made is
when the Berlin Wall came down which
side ran to which side it's fairly
obvious why would you want to live in a
system where you're just suffering the
whole time you wouldn't now the idea of
the Communist says get rid of the free
radicals find the cogs who are blind and
happy to be blind and they will be happy
and they will owe nothing
yeah I always thought it was weird how
they went after the Intelligentsia and
in the Soviet Union I was like of course
why why oh they're the ones that would
challenge me radicals gotta get rid of
the freeways man one antioxidants one
problem with um decentralization is in
finance if you truly have a
decentralized financial system then
there's no organized currency and
without organized currency it's almost
like we don't really have a country
without a a unified dollar so if
everyone had their own currency Ian coin
fill coin like it I don't know I think
that would be a lot more chaotic and
therefore potentially destructive of a
world to live in so in that I I value
currency uh centralization but I don't
want a central bank controlling all the
flow you need checks and balances yeah
you're gonna have a central system so
like you need to audit the Federal
Reserve and any anything that's
attempting to control the money or get
rid of it
um yeah you could but change it for
something else like that Indiana Jones
move where he like puts the the bag of
sand on it you want a new thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time